dans vos cours de maths vous avez
sûrement déjà cauchemarder sur des
équations compliqué un problème de
géométrie incompréhensibles ou des
théorèmes qui vous paraît c'est absurde
mais est ce que vous saviez que cette
façon d'apprendre des mathématiques a
pour origine un homme encore vivant un
homme fantomatique et légendaires dont
on ne connaît quasiment que le nom
nicolas bourbaki personne ne l'a jamais
vu pourtant son influence plane au
dessus de chacun de tes cours de maths
laissez-moi vous emmener sur les traces
du mystérieux mathématicien français qui
à lui tout seul a bouleversé
l'enseignement des mathématiques
modernes dans le monde entier le
traumatisme des mathématiques modernes
tout commence durant les années 30 à
l'époque les mathématiques c'est un
fouillis gigantesque chaque domaine à
son langage propre ses méthodes et sa
façon d'enseigner les mathématiques à
cause de sa ba bonne chance pour essayer
de faire évoluer les maths faut dire
qu'en plus la première guerre mondiale
avait foutu un sacré bordel notamment
dans la science de nombreux élus ne
supportant plus la situation actuelle et
voulant repartir son nouveau fondement
un homme va sortir de l'ombre avec la
ferme attention de tout balayer un
mystérieux n point bourbaki le seul
bourbaki qu'on connaît à cette époque et
charles denis bourbaki un vieux général
de guerre franco prussienne mort depuis
des années mais n bourbaki il n'y a
aucune trace de sa scolarité ou de ses
diplômes à temps il va commencer à
publier une série d'ouvragés nommé
éléments de mathématiques qui
al'ambition d'unifier les mathématiques
sous un même blason et rien que
l'élaboration du plan détaillé a mis
plusieurs années
il va offrir une classification moderne
et inédite des mathématiques il va
s'emparer de chaque branche une à une la
logique la théorie des ensembles
l'analyse la topologie et j'en passe
tout débroussailler réécrire démontrer
réexpliqué pour enfin réunir les maths
sous un unique langage clair et précis
fini les mathématiques
on parle maintenant de là
thématique et ses livres ont encore une
influence aujourd'hui derrière la part
de ce que vous étudiez en cours se cache
l'ombre de bourbaki c je vous assure
vous voyez ces symboles logique vous
doit ses notations à cet étrange
mathématicien mais ça ne s'arrête pas là
les définitions la façon d'écrire les
mathématiques
là encore c'est le style bourbaki dans
les années 60 on va sous son impulsion
entièrement revoir la façon dont on
enseignait les mathématiques peut-être
même un peu trop en fait
si vos parents étaient en cours à cette
époque et que vous leur parlez de
mathématiques vous verrez probablement
leur visage se dit qu'ils fier sous la
peur et pour cause dès le collège
on a décidé d'enseigner les notions de
bac +2 de mathématiques
ça nous semble totalement fou mais
c'était le cas car il fallait enseigner
toutes les bases fondamentales des
mathématiques dès le plus jeune âge avec
des ensembles et non pas des nombres et
calcule les élèves les parents et même
les professeurs et des hors-jeu
personnes étaient au niveau pour
comprendre la réforme a tourné au fiasco
plusieurs membres qu'il avait instaurée
au démissionné et la réforme fut annulée
en 1973 néanmoins quelques élèves de
cette époque s'en sont plutôt bien
sortis
et on les compte aujourd'hui parmi les
plus grands mathématiciens de notre
temps si la france rayonne autant
mathématiques c'est à peu près grâce à
cette réforme ratée une secte autour
d'un mathématicien imaginaire revenons à
ce cher bourbach encore aujourd'hui 80
ans après elle bourbaki continue de
publier ses trouvailles mathématiques
attend 80 ans après s'il a commencé à
écrire à la vingtaine ça voudrait dire
qu'il a plus de sens tant le mec ça sent
le truc louche là en même temps un gars
qui débarque de nulle part sans être
passé par aucune école mais qui pond des
livres qui révolutionne les
mathématiques ça paraît un peu gros à
avaler non aujourd'hui on sait que
nicolas bourbaki n'a jamais existé
nicolas bourbaki est en réalité un
groupe de mathématiciens anonyme
le groupe étant constituée d'étudiants
de l'école normale supérieure
cet anonymat n'est pas une simple
fantaisie dans ce contexte tendu
ils ont décidé de prendre un pseudonyme
afin de diffuser leurs ouvrages sans
être la cible de critiques leur
reprochant d'être de jeune arriviste qui
profite que leurs aînés soient tombés au
combat pendant la guerre
prendre la place laissée vacante le but
était aussi de supprimer les égos
personne ne pouvait publier en son nom
et sa personne mais pourquoi ce pseudo
en particulier au début ce pseudo était
n point bourbaki ou le m était placée là
de manière random puis s'est transformé
au fil des ouvrages ans nicolas tandis
que le nom bourbaki lui admet plusieurs
théories plus folles les unes que les
autres
d'après le général bourbaki ou même en
hommage à un ancien mathématicien
bourbach youth certains parlent même
d'une histoire de hérisson bref sa vraie
signification fait encore partie des
mystères de bourbaki qui reste bien
gardé
parmi les règles du groupe dont
l'anonymat il n'y en a une très cool et
progressistes c'est la limite d'âge il
est décidé qu'à l'âge de 50 ans tous
membres de bomba qui devra céder sa
place au jeune génération parce que et
je cite un de ses membres à 50 ans on
est devenus qu'on la majorité des
membres connus sont à ce jour retirés du
groupe pour ceux encore en activité le
secret reste total le seul d'entre eux
dont le nom a fuité et antoine
chamberland loire enseignant chercheur à
l'université d'orsay qui devra quitter
d'ici peu le groupe puisqu'il à bientôt
50 ans donc aujourd'hui on connaît une
nouvelle génération de bourbaki sts avec
des membres plus jeunes choisis parmi
l'élite des mathématiciens dont
l'identité reste encore un secret on
peut voir ce groupe comme une sorte de
secte des mathématiques autour d'une
seule et même kg zoopsie danton shônen
favoris se seraient de vrais chichi
boukai les plus grands cerveaux des
mathématiques en font aujourd'hui partie
à tel point qu'on retrouve parmi les
membres connus cinq médailles fields la
médaille fields et la récompense
considérée comme la plus prestigieuse
des mathématiques au même titre que le
prix nobel pour les autres domaines
oui parce que il n'ya pas de nobel en
mathématiques selon la légende le
fondateur des nobel a été trompé par sa
maîtresse qui a couché avec un
mathématicien
il avait la haine et c'est pourquoi il
aurait décidé qu'il n'y aurait jamais de
mathématiciens nobélisé l'excellence des
livres de bourbaki tient également à la
méthode de rédaction du groupe
un membre écrit un chapitre puis tout le
collectif va le relire le corriger le
réécrire puis l'euro corrigés des 10
n 2 fois jusqu'à ce que le texte soit le
plus juste précis et clair possible
c'est d'ailleurs un peu de cette façon
qu'on écrit nos vidéos sur science trash
enfin le génie en moins malgré tous ces
savants respectable ne se privait pas de
quelques petites plaisanteries
un exemple il diffusait des poèmes
lyriques sur des concepts mathématiques
en profitant au passage pour critiquer
un peu leurs détracteurs pour rendre
encore le personnage le plus crédible
possible il publié même dans les
journaux de faut faire part de mariage
ou de décès fantaisiste au nom de la
famille bourbaki histoire de brouiller
encore plus les pistes
à propos de son existence pour se sentir
un peu teg il est truffé de blagues
mathématiques incompréhensible pour les
vulgaires moldus que nous sommes ils ont
même inventé un pays la pole d'evidon
serait originaire bourbaki il fallait en
effet une histoire ce personnage pour le
faire reconnaître par l'académie des
sciences
et s'il n'avait pas existé les
mathématiques aurait pris une toute
autre forme même si la publication de
bourbaki aujourd'hui quasiment à l'arrêt
à cause notamment de l'explosion du
nombre de branchements dans les
mathématiques
bon bah qui continue de vivre à travers
les prestigieuses séminaire annuel y
être invité et faire un exposé est un
immense honneur et propulsé la carrière
d'un mathématicien
mais attention le milieu est cruel si au
milieu de votre présentation un membre
reconnu montre de l'agacement ouvre son
journal ou s'assoupit vous voilà renier
par la communauté
je n'ai pas vraiment trouvé de vidéos
youtube sur les aventures de nicolas
bourbaki
c'était donc pour moi l'occasion de ne
pas l'oublier d'écrire son histoire
aussi en vidéo sur internet
néanmoins si vous êtes curieux il existe
un super échange d'une heure trente
entre plusieurs anciens membres de
nicolas bourbaki où on apprend tous les
secrets les plus personnelles des
membres du mathématicien et souvent je
me passe in devant l'histoire qu'ils y
adhèrent ces formules comprendre d'où
vient une idée un concept
cela permet de mieux s'en imprégner
merci à jason un camarade de promo qui
gère la chaîne automates sur youtube il
a grandement aidé sur le sujet
d'ailleurs n'hésitez pas à les voir sa
dernière vidéo sur le théorème de gianni
un théorème qu'il affectionne tout
particulièrement par sa simplicité de
son énoncé mais aussi par l'élégance de
sa démonstration
c'était ma tard j'espère que vous avez
apprécié le voyage car je voulais à
travers cette vidéo pour faire vivre une
partie de ce qui m'anime dans mon
quotidien
la passion des maths et vous